almost 3,000 people were shot in the
city of Chicago last year men women
small children sometimes alone sometimes
in groups many hundreds of them died not
a single one of those people received
anything like the attention the media
have lavished on a relatively minor
assault alleged by the television actor
Jesse Smollett on the other hand none of
Chicago's 3,000 shootings was even half
as useful as small that story his story
had everything the national media long
ago gave up the pretense of gathering
news journalism is now explicitly a
political job the point of it is to
enforce cultural orthodoxies and punish
enemies Jesse Smollett was the perfect
vehicle for both of those things
journalists pretended to be horrified as
they were accounted what he said
happened to him but secretly they were
thrilled
there are many indications of a hate
crime here they are looking for two
suspects who were apparently wearing
make America great again hats though
that has not yet been officially
confirmed we don't know what happened to
Jesse but what we do know is that racism
is alive and well in this country there
is real evidence of people who have done
these crimes who cite that the president
has inspired them the fact that it
reportedly said this is my country adds
to sort of the the atmosphere of Menace
that African Americans in particular and
people of color in general have felt
since the the advent of the Trump
administration and the media has really
cast so much doubt on his story which I
find so personally offensive that a gay
black man is targeted and then suddenly
he becomes the victim of people's
disbelief he said his attackers hurled
racial and homophobic slurs at him
this is America in 2019 this is America
in 2019 to the national media sports
story was the perfect metaphor for the
Trump era it was also pretty clearly a
total crock some let's account began to
fall apart within hours after a series
of leaks from the obviously skeptical
Chicago Police Department some lets
handlers paired him with a network
anchor they could rely on to launder the
hoax
in the ends when it set for 16 and a
half minutes with Robin Roberts of Good
Morning America Robert surely knew there
was ample evidence that SWAT was lying
but she decided to ignore that instead
Roberts colluded with him she nodded
empathetically as snow at wept on camera
she has no significant follow-up
questions the two parted like old
friends
both Smollett and Roberts turned out to
be talented actors check out their
performance on YouTube before it's
scrubbed you'll never watch ABC news
again virtually every word they utter is
dishonest so what began by explaining
that the men who attacked him were not
muggers they didn't want money they
assaulted him purely because his of his
identity as a gay black Democrat people
like Jesse Smollett aren't allowed to
live in Donald Trump's America that was
the message of the attackers this is
magnet country they screamed they were
referring of course to Chicago a city
where 88% of the population voted
against Donald Trump as a crime story it
didn't make a lot of sense
and when skeptics on the Internet raised
basic questions about his story Smollett
attacked them as racist if I had said
it was a Muslim or Mexican or someone
black I feel like the doubters would
have supported me a lot much more a lot
more and that says a lot about the place
that we are in our country right now the
fact that we have these fear Mongols
these people that are trying to separate
us and it's just not okay what she just
heard is a near-perfect inversion of the
truth as somewhat himself might have put
it who exactly is the fear mongrel here
who is dividing us and who exactly is
the victim in all of this well small
claims that he's the victim he tells us
that he represents the most despised in
unfashionable groups in America that's
why bigots doubt his story the rest of
us not as if this were true because
we're required to do that
that's how dishonest our society has
become everyone must lie all the time
we know the rules we have no choice
meanwhile our leaders immediately jump
to the defense of this supposedly
unpopular person before even hearing the
evidence within hours at least two
presidential candidates had described
what happened to Sublette as they quote
attempted lynching they assumed on faith
that he must be telling the truth by
definition they smeared anyone who
doubted him they called him a hero is
this the treatment that marginalized
people receive no hardly somewhat isn't
powerless far from it his power lies in
pretending that he has no power in fact
Jesse Smollett and his promoters are the
aggressors in this story they launched a
calculated campaign of slander against
an entire group of people who have far
less wealth and far less cultural
influence than they have if there is a
bias crime here they committed it well
he wouldn't be held accountable for this
don't bet on it
in 1987 al Sharpton introduced the media
to a young woman called Tawana Brawley
Brawley had an awful story to tell she
said she'd been viciously raped by a
group of racist white men and left in a
garbage bag she was covered in feces
with racial slurs scrawled on her body
the Brawley case dominated headlines
across the country for more than a year
and it bitterly divided New York City
along ethnic lines people hated each
other because of what Tawana Brawley
said happened to her but it was all a
lie after conducting hundreds of
interviews a grand jury declared the
entire story fraudulent none of it
actually happened Broly fled the state a
judge ordered al Sharpton to pay for
damages for accusing innocent men of
rape that should have been the end of Al
Sharpton's career yet just the opposite
happened before he promoted to Juana
brawly's lie Sharpton was best known as
a small-time hustler an FBI informant
from Brooklyn a man who'd once been
James Brown's road manager after he
perpetuated the single most destructive
racial hoax in memory
al Sharpton got a promotion he became a
world-famous civil rights leader he ran
for president he became a policy advisor
to Barack Obama
according to visitor logs al Sharpton
was invited to the Obama White House
more than 80 times he got his own show
on MSNBC which he still has Sharpton has
never apologized or even acknowledged
the harm he did to this country by the
lying about Tawana Brawley no one has
forced him to the lesson of Al Sharpton
was clear to everyone watching there are
no penalties for hate hoaxes there are
only rewards not surprisingly there have
been many more since the incident
escalated dramatically after the 2016
election the Muslim student in Louisiana
who claims she was assaulted by racists
in Trump hats the Muslim woman in San
Diego who alleged the same an anti Asian
attack in Minnesota an anti-gay attack
in California racial attack in Delaware
racist graffiti at the Air Force Academy
anti-semitic threats phoned in to Jewish
community centers all fake those and
many many more the much-hyped epidemic
of hate crimes you've heard so much
about essentially is made up the premise
is absurd America is not a hateful
country it's the most welcoming place on
earth that's why even as our children
learn from their teachers what a bigoted
country this is millions continue to
stream in from Africa and Latin America
for a better life here it's why we've
welcomed more refugees and immigrants
than any
in history it's why we rescued a young
Ilhan Omar from a refugee camp in Kenya
we are kind people you see it in your
own life how many violent racists do you
know personally none probably that's
because there aren't many in America the
left has to invent them stoking race
hatred ensures continued power for the
Democratic Party divided populations are
easier to manipulate and rule there
would be no Democratic coalition without
racial animosity it's what holds their
constituencies together that's the point
of identity politics it's why there
forever reopening the wound it's why Al
Sharpton is still a revered figure among
Democratic office holders but to the
cost to the country has been high ask
the kids from Covington Catholic for the
crime of having unfashionable political
beliefs in skin color
a group of entirely innocent high school
students came close to having their
lives destroyed that didn't happen by
accident the national media did it they
concocted a hate crime out of nothing
the Twitter mob that demanded that those
boys be expelled from school and marked
for life
their parents were threatened their
classmates were harassed
after two days video surfaced proving
that none of it was real the mob moved
on but what if exculpatory video had not
emerged CNN panels would still be
screaming for their blood you sometimes
hear people wonder why the media never
seemed to learn anything for moments
like these moments when they're exposed
as corrupt and reckless and so the
answer to that question is very simple
it never occurs to them that they may be
wrong or they might have something to
learn the media see themselves as
teachers not as students if you ever
tried to put a sleepy four-year-old into
a snow suit before school you know how
journalists feel about the audience it's
frustrating when children don't
understand or obey but you've got to
keep trying that's how they feel listen
is that oily media reporter kid from CNN
explains that the Jesse Smollett hoax
does not in any way reflect poorly on
the people who promoted it perhaps the
questioning was not tough enough on Good
Morning America so ultimately this is
not about the media or about politicians
or activists or any of the people that
might have been fooled it's about just
me oh yeah it's about Jesse it
it has nothing to do with any of us in
the media who uncritically repeated his
lies night after night for political
effect it's Jesse's problem now that's
Nancy Pelosi's new position to by the
way almost immediately after a Smollett
story hit the news wires the Speaker of
the House denounced the racist and
homophobic attack quote may we all
commit to ending this hate once and for
all
Pelosi has since deleted that tweet she
has not apologized for her own role in
perpetuating that hate Pelosi should
apologize and not simply because it's
good manners hate hoaxes make ethnic
groups fear and distrust each other
that's a dangerous thing to do in a
country that's becoming more diverse by
the day the only way to prevent future
Tawana Brawley x' and justice Millette
is for the people who have promoted
these lies to acknowledge what they've
done ask for forgiveness for doing it
and pledge to stop judging others on the
basis of racial stereotypes we need to
resolve the justice Millette story we
can't just move on to the next thing and
act like it never happened which is
their plan so let himself made that
point actually at the end of his
interview on Good Morning America watch
I still want to believe with it
everything that has happened that
there's something called justice we've
got that in common something called
justice we all want to believe in that